la voix feutrée de carre moualek qui a
touché le public avec des chansons comme
l'amour s'est éteinte prématurément
l'auteur compositeur interprète qui
venait d'avoir 37 ans a été trouvé sans
vie lundi soir à l'intérieur du studio
l'unisson dans le quartier saint-roch à
québec
l'annoncé de son décès laisse la
communauté artistique sous le choc
stupéfaction c'est ça a été un choc ce
matin comme pour tout le monde et et
karim avait cette capacité là d'intégrer
des influences américaines un peu r'n'b
et pop parce qu'ils venaient beaucoup de
ce côté là pour former une pop vraiment
assumé très vivante des refrains
incroyable
déjà évoque la grande complicité qui
s'était développée durant la réalisation
des trois albums de karim ouellette ce
soit que
le québec qui parle de lui pis je trouve
que
de la natation comme énormément d'amour
qui ressort de tout ça puis on voit à
quel point il ya marqué les gens la
soeur de karim wallet la rappeuse sarah
may a publié un message ou non de sa
famille par le biais des réseaux sociaux
pour toujours nous continuerons de
célébrer sa vie son talent et son
héritage merci pour ce torrent d'amour
pour karim né à dakar au sénégal karim
wallet a grandi au québec après avoir
été adoptée dès 2007 il se fait
connaître en collaborant avec plusieurs
artistes de la capitale
avec son deuxième album intitulé fox
karim wallet acquiert une grande
popularité et remporte plusieurs prix
dont le prestigieux juno de l'album
francophone de l'année en 2014
au fil des ans il participe à des
événements d'envergure comme la fête du
canada et accompagne en tournée le
célèbre straumann le premier ministre
françois legault a salué le nouveau
style qu'il a apporté à la musique
québécoise justin trudeau a pour sa part
rappelé son esprit créatif et avant
gardiste avec une bonne musique puis la
musique intéressante
le bureau du coroner tentera de
déterminer la cause du décès de
l'artiste
la thèse criminelle est écartée
[Musique]
on